Thank You Anil who's Donna who's done
anal
who has done anal who's done anal
who here has done anal who's done anal
who has I don't have a lot of time who
has done a saving a hard question whose
fried it who's tried to try it trying to
try it is different than trying it when
you're trying to try it you'd stop
you're like Who am I all the sudden yeah
pull this off is hard to do it's like
trying to get a lime into a Corona it's
just a perfect analogy you're right
you're right every new clap thing that's
a perfect analogy it is it's hard to get
that lime in there it's gonna take a lot
of work it's gonna be messy you're gonna
get [ __ ] everywhere and you finally get
it in there you're like did I even want
that in there they don't do this in
Mexico and Here I am didn't like that
first job I just be pretty religious I
used to go to church all the time and I
did mushrooms I was like well that
phases not gonna go to God's house if
he's clearly willing to come to mind if
you think Jesus was white you're not
allowed to have an opinion on gun
control that's right that's right heavy
hitter I'm coming at you with the hard
stuff
let's ah thought I can read the crowd I
can read you guys let's softball it out
of that TSA what's going on at the
airport what's going on they're taking
our shoes off I don't when you get to
the airport and they tell you to take
your shoes off it's like cool your jets
we all know the shoe thing by now it's
2016 if someone shows up like what I
have to take my shoes off arrest and
kill that person
they're probably not a terrorist but
they're holding up the line and that's
enough for me
I mean what what is terrorism anyways
like on a local level what is it like
holding up the line yes in my everyday
life that's terrorism you know what else
TSA nobody gets dressed and undressed
while moving sideways at home so calm
down when we're not amazing at it right
out of the gate
no one's getting off work had a great
time at work today no no I got it Kathy
shut up I got it
it's flying to Salt Lake so you guys
been to Salt Lake City the whitest
couple of people the whitest city in the
world did you know that I used to say it
was the whitest city in the country and
then I took a step back I said you know
what worry I bet we can go world on this
one it's real Heights it's very it's a
lot of white people and I'm not talking
about snow white I'm not about nose
candy white people what it's creepy if
Hitler could have seen footage of Salt
Lake City today he would have been like
guys we shouldn't be doing this this is
not right this is bad this is creepy
this is not what I picture
there are 12 black people in Salt Lake
City and they all play for the Utah Jazz
you're right you're in your first
instinct is right racism
yeah the Jazz changed the name of the
team go with smooth jazz represent the
entire city don't act like you don't
know what smooth jazz is you know what
smooth jazz is it's the jazz white
people got ahold of jazz was doing just
fine give me that let me see what my
white fingers can turn it into and
immediately we turn it into
[Music]
Chuck it's me your cousin Marvin Marvin
Barry remember how you were looking for
songs for people to kill themselves to
listen to this hey are you just sitting
around wondering if she's ever gonna
come back smooth jazz hey somebody's got
to throw all these pebbles into this
pond smooth jazz
[Applause]